sure I was crazy about her and she and I
in fact I had a clued hairdo for a
couple of years did you did you really
yeah wow I have I I looked almost as
well as you the reason that we worked
together in nine to five was I I went
and saw her in appearing nightly as a
one-woman show where she plays a lot of
different characters but it's not yeah
in search of signs of intelligent life
so I went down to the amundsen here and
I saw her and I I that was it I was in
love I mean I just I've never seen
anything like it she became so many
different people and and just became
them profoundly
became them yeah I mean everything about
her changed with each character and I
just I I just thought well I'm not going
to make a movie about secretaries unless
she's in it I don't want to ever do
anything without her I just Will Smith